sonny gray he has been very consistent
for the last couple of months yes he has
been very consistent you know what he's
consistent in john is his approach to
the game he's an absolute grinder
smoke to suarez fire to first in time
double play
do they call it the hot corner it
happens so quickly down there thomas
really not a chance to get back that
ball was hit to him and he made the
catch he was thinking first base wasted
no time getting rid of it and he gets
thomas easily on the double play so bell
had a good night last night third inning
rbi single a walk another base hit in
the seventh
that ball is rocked into right beating
the shift and this ball is going all the
way to the wall juan soto digging for
third
bob henley is going to send it here he
comes he is safe at the plate and josh
bell ends up at third
most probably a double and third on the
throw but what a great swing a fastball
inside looking to pull the hands and get
to barrel the baseball and he hit it so
hard it went all the way to the wall
juan soto off to the races with two outs
gets it past castiganos looked like
castiganos might have been able to cut
that ball off he let it roll all the way
the wall and that let bob henley
send juan soto juan soto does not get
enough credit and here's paulo espino in
one game against the reds three innings
two hits three runs otto's heated back
up 360 average in his last nine games
three balls two strikes it's on the way
fastball popped up playable left field
straight away stevenson calling for it
makes the catch espino wins the battle
with joey votto no runners one ends up
in the second
kaybert ruiz
oh
ruiz hits around one deep right
castellanos
see
you
later two-nothing nets he had one as a
dodger this is his first one in a
washington uniform 85 102 on the exit
velocity i guarantee the launch angle
was super high i'm going to say over 30.
armors at first one man out reds are
trailing the nationals two to nothing as
they bat in the bottom of the second
inning espino to the belt swing the
ground ball slowly hit right side garcia
has it flips to sacramento escobar on to
first a double play four to six to three
backhand shovel for garcia but with
barnard running they had plenty of time
so hot hit it hard first time but right
at
suarez for that double play
fastball rocked by escobar
deep center
c
u
later to the batter's eye
his third of the year
what a way to get a 10 game hitting
streak right around the trade deadline
we said you know what let's see how
these guys develop let's see how they're
playing towards the end of september and
evaluate this team then this is an
exciting team to watch right now
another walk another time on base heads
up piggy
juan's coming to get you his nationals
record on base street continues he's
reached bay's 12 consecutive played
appearances
here's gray's delivery and a swing and a
looping line drive shallow right that is
going to fall in for a hit in front of
castillanos
soto jogs in to score k barrett ruiz
with an rbi single to right field he's
driven in a pair tonight and the
nationals lead it four to nothing as
they are taking it to sonny gray early
in this ball game two outs full count
friedle is going to fly
well hit to right
talk about grinding out and a bat
finally gets one that he can handle with
the continued foul balls down the left
field line you had to know that
schrock was looking for a pitch close to
him that's and that was not where espino
wanted the
the new reds pitcher
is amir garrett amir's been trending
this is one of his better months i think
his best month statistically
his third full count today
oh he seemed to go yes
and the run ends at a dozen amir garrett
strikes out juan soto that's just got to
feel so foreign for him walking back to
the dugout made a great slider right
there down at the bottom of the zone oh
not gonna get him fishing too much
especially not with the run he's been on
delight of the shields hitting in the
pitcher's spot
well hit d blip center
delino de shields
one
run
game
shave all the hair off your face
and go deep that's just a great swing
right there man i'm telling you that
didn't look like a guy who had did a
home run in two years that's that's a
bolt right there
castillanos couple of ground ball outs
first pitch and bounce to third in the
opening inning
center field
deep shot
[Applause]
his career high 30th home run hola
looks like nick found himself another
new
piece of dangerous lumber and i think he
talked that one a little bit
get up boy get up ball get up ball
suarez
deep left center ridge lead
second a little hispanic heritage
tonight magic right there john
absolutely the case
gino suarez with the big time profund
a little spanglish
this crowd wants lorenzo to get it done
they know how good how hot soda has been
out to suarez
top of the order
one two three conference here do you
walk castellanos to go left on left with
motto
i would pick your poison right last time
up castellanos tied to the game here's a
bullet up the middle that's a base hit
into left center field freedle will
score aquino rounds second on to third
seven for red take the cap off
hit the 30th home run
right back
into smoking hot again
the man
can hit back-to-back
safe situation michael gibbons is in
and here's escobar hasn't fared well
against gibbons career this would be a
great time to go one for seven
[Applause]
left field corner
thomas will score
escobar will go to second and soto will
bat
seven to five they're loaded that's down
by two
target was the middle of the zone that's
a base hit escobar home here comes soto
the nets
have tied it
with three in the ninth
unbelievable the 21 year old with the
game on the line down to his last strike
puts the ball in play there's nobody
there and this game is tied at seven two
on two out tied at seven justin wilson
in his biggest spot as a red
farmer
short way to second we go bottom nine
here's another chance for the reds
with a man in scoring position
swing and a miss on a slider down and
away
we are
michael gibbons obviously had some
trouble in that ninth inning but for the
most part this bullpen has been really
good today and luis tessa has been
exceptional
barnhart sheds the mass
makes the catch
three up three down against sesame to
the bottom of the 10th that's trying to
win an extra inning game it's been tough
to do that this year austin vote will
get the call
he got a breaking ball right side garcia
to zimmerman let's go 11. shall we luis
garcia 0 for 8 in the series
before his most recent at bat do it
again 21 year old
[Applause]
he just
got him
the reds are four for their last 34 with
men in scoring position
that ball cracked it kicks off the glove
freedom given the wave shallow ride solo
bare hand throw home freedom scores and
the reds win it
aquino
coming up with the big hit you can see
garcia
trying to work underneath that ball but
hit too hard
trickles away
speedy freedom
scores easily
it was a struggle for the team